[Music]
a day that offers a glimpse into the
secretive world of China's Communist
party for a few hours the media are
allowed into beijing's Great Hall of the
people for a tightly controlled pageant
[Music]
the opening of the party Congress held
every five years
and this one's being closely watched
normally Chinese leaders stand down
after serving 10 years in office
but Xi Jinping is expected to break
convention by being appointed for
another five years
he presented himself as a humble servant
of the party but a party that's been
remade In His Image says one expert so
having seized control of the Chinese
Communist Party Xi Jinping then sees
control of China and China has become a
lot less free a lot more oppressive far
less open than it was 10 years ago
the Congress comes at a turbulent time
for China she's zero covered policy has
trapped millions of people in a series
of stop-start lockdowns borders remain
closed to most foreigners many overseas
investors have fled
she's Focus here though was on the
positive
we adhere to the principles of people
first life first and also firmly adhere
to the dynamic zero covet policy to
carry out the fight against the pandemic
the people's War to protect the people's
life and physical health to the maximum
by the time this Congress ends XI
jinping's grip on power will likely be
absolute
without the people of China having their
say
Adrian Brown Al Jazeera